[Music]
dancing for science once a week
pensioners come to the University of
magdeburg for dance lessons some are
over 80 years old and really put their
heart and soul into it they know that
exercise keeps them fit and old age and
movement isn't just good for the body
but also for the mind sportive in
zaventem cool physical activity raises
the level of oxygen in the brain in
principle all types of exercise help to
improve the supply to the brain and thus
have a positive effect on mental
abilities and welcomes a stomach let's
NDRF the cognitive a few at millers
so how does exercise influence the brain
for 18 months one group of 50 senior
citizens has been dancing for science
while another has been pursuing
endurance sports the particular
challenge but dancing is that you have
to orient yourself in space and learn
new steps each lesson the vehicle Minh
is encoding latifah in terms of
coordination the movements are highly
demanding because you're constantly
having to create combinations of arm
head torso and leg movements it's
communites you own that I see you also
have to reel off several elements one
after another in your head so the
ability to retain information also gets
a lot of training indeed the dancers
improved both their alertness and memory
function scoring better grades than the
group that pursued endurance sports with
the help of magnetic resonance imaging
the scientists were able to make visible
exactly where in the brain changes
resulting from regular dance lessons
take place the results showed that above
all those areas responsible for learning
and information retention and for the
speed of information processing
increased in volume so dancing can
increase mental fitness but only if the
training is regular
via Hamdi amatya of Nam we compared the
magnetic resonance images and we found
that neurogenesis brain building drops
off if the intensity of training
decreases so if you want new cells to
form in your brain you have to be active
at least twice a week no se dong dongs
ottoman ministers by martin abajo
evocative sign
[Applause]
[Music]